Ucrania está lista para iniciar su
esperada contraofensiva así lo aseguró
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
microculeva recibimos suficientes armas
para comenzar la contraofensiva una cosa
es Tener suficiente armamento para
empezarla pero otra cosa es asegurar la
sostenibilidad de los suministros para
continuar el tiempo que se necesite
desde no dijo si la contraofensiva ya
comenzó según él la fecha es irrelevante
y lo único que importa es terminar con
la victoria de Ucrania los comentarios
llegan apenas unas horas después de que
el ministro de defensa de Rusia
publicará este vídeo tomado por un dron
que dicen marca el comienzo de la
ofensiva ucraniana y que según Moscú se
trata de una operación fracasada
el enemigo no logró sus tareas no tuvo
éxito como resultado de las acciones
capaces y calculadas del grupo de
fuerzas en el este el ejército ucraniano
sufrió pérdidas de más de 250 personas
16 tanques tres vehículos blindados de
reporte de personal y 21 vehículos
blindados el 4 de mayo el presidente
dijo a un periódico que su país ahora
está listo para recuperar el territorio
ocupado por Rusia y un día después dio
alientos a sus soldados
estoy agradecido con cada uno de
nuestros soldados todos nuestros
Defensores que Durante este día han
brindado las noticias que estábamos
esperando buen trabajo soldados en el
sector de bakmut vemos como Rusia
reacciona una histéricamente a cada paso
ya sea que ha comenzado o no la ofensiva
ucraniana Lo cierto es que no solo es
esperado por los mismos ucranianos al
ser consultado sobre las recientes
operaciones de kiev Y si serían exitosas
Joe biden atinó a cruzar los dedos en
señal de apoyo a su Aliado
todo mientras en el terreno hay
actualmente enfrentamientos en varias
secciones de la línea del frente
indicando que la tan esperada
contraofensiva podría estar en marcha